each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
introduce my colleague Jim lares who is
the director of research and strategy
within the extreme computing group for
those of you that many academics here in
fact almost everybody's an academic year
we'll Jim is a former professor from the
University of Wisconsin and before he
got lured here mmm several years ago got
too many many years ago years ago since
he's been here he's done a number of
projects run the languages into little
groups he was responsible for probably
the first major OS other than windows
out of microsoft recently that's a
singularity project which has been
released the academic community I
believe that's right and now he's been
planning our strategy for programming
the cloud within the extreme computing
group and leading earlier research
efforts and now you're gonna hear about
some research stuff right Thank You
Dennis yes you're gonna hear about some
research stuff so it's good you guys
heard those two talks beforehand to see
where the world is I'm going to sort of
try to anticipate where the world is
going which is what research is supposed
to do and maybe even drive what it looks
like when we get there so I'm starting
with the premise that something i'm
going to call cloud computing is the
next computing platform you know cloud
computing is this overloaded term some
people use them to talk about you know
amazon which is a platform some used to
talk about azor which is you know
platform because of some software on it
I'm going to use it in a much more
general sense i'm talking about cloud
computing as the combination of lots of
interconnected devices some of them
things like you know the iphone some of
them embedded systems some of them are
pcs+ this vast computing resources that
are available to you in the cloud some
of which can be services like a sure
some of which can be just the existing
website some of them can be things like
Google or Bing or search like that I'm
viewing this whole thing as a computing
platform and I want to talk about sort
of how do we get there and how do we
make it accessible as a platform
arm for lots of programmers to use not
just sort of elite level programmers
like you would see in universities or in
Microsoft you know the starting point is
basically anything can be a client you
know it's relatively cheap these days to
add network connectivity to a device you
know you can argue about whether we have
enough wireless bandwidth which we don't
but basically it doesn't cost very much
I mean think about something like kindle
this little reader and it comes with a
cellular phone modem built-in just so
you can download the books transparently
okay so you know the starting premise I
have is that in the history of computing
there have been a number of these
platform changes and each one of these
platform changes has been enabled by
sort of new technology which is driven
new software which has led to radical
changes in the way in which we do
computing and the players in the
computing market I mean you go back to
the mainframes and really you know IBM
took advantage of transistors to build
the first mainframes around the 360
series and then the integrated circuits
came and we came with the mini computers
and then you know vlsi came along and
you able to put a computer on a chip and
Intel came along and we had pcs and
Microsoft and then we have cloud
computing so where is that going to take
us well I see us is going in this world
of a large number of devices they're not
going to look like computers I mean
we're the PCs are not going away I mean
I don't think any of you could really
imagine throwing away all of your
computing devices that look like pcs and
replacing them with iPhones you can do a
lot of things with iphones and you can
do a lot of new things with iphones but
you're are not going to sit there and
write a paper on one apparently in japan
you can write a novel on one but i don't
think most people are going to go that
direction but much more interesting than
that is the fact that there are going to
be all these specialized devices and
they're going to be part of your network
too and they're really going to depend
upon a cloud to connect them together so
you know a good example of that from my
mind is the kindle is that you know
here's this device that sort of you know
could be a free-standing device but it's
a lot more valuable because it's
connected to the internet you can go to
the website and you can
I a book and all of a sudden it just
appears there and the web is where the
cloud is what makes it seamless and
transparent to the user to use this
device it's a lot more convenient than
trying to find the book on the kindle
itself if any of you have ever tried
that so we're moving in this direction
how are we going to get there and how
are we going to program it and I'm
really focused on the latter question
rather than the first question which is
a business question as much as anything
so the group that Dennis and I are part
of is the extreme computing group and
what we're interested in is this entire
ecosystem from the hardware that's in
the data center through the operating
system in the data center of the user
that you heard about earlier to the data
center software and I just put a couple
examples up there to the client hardware
and the client software because this
whole thing is the platform you know if
you think about it we are going to have
to be able to write software that runs
in multiple places so if you're going to
write an application it's not just going
to be a data center application in the
future if there's going to be
specialized hardware around it and
similarly if you're going to write a
client application what are you going to
back it up with just public websites
it's not going to have very much
functionality that distinguishes it from
anybody else's as we've all seen from
the eye appt phone apps store where
basically any good idea gets cloned and
copied in no time at all so our group
the extreme computing group is trying to
look across this entire stack and
basically sort of look for places where
there's a innovation that can occur
where we can change the hardware and the
software at the same time and really
develop new solutions they are and I'm
not going to be able to talk about all
of it today I'm going to focus on one
part of it which is how do you program
this or what are the challenges that are
involved in writing software for this
world I'm going to sort of quickly march
through the challenges and then I'm
going to talk a little bit about the
solution that we're building which is a
system called Orleans so first challenge
and I'd say the distinguishing challenge
here is scale so think about it
basically if you're putting up a cloud
service and that's your business you can
go from zero to four hundred million
people using your service in the matter
of a couple years and they're all sort
of sitting there on your platform
man you're running your their software
concurrently 7 by 24 all the time that's
a real challenge you're basically
building the equivalent of you know more
than the infrastructure the it of the
United States for more people than are
in the United States and you did this in
a couple years starting from zero this
is a huge challenge because we've made
things available we've provided a
seamless network around the globe and if
something takes off it really takes off
and it has to be continuously available
and you have to figure out how to make
money on and as our previous speakers
pointed out it's an unreliable platform
so you basically have to assume that
things are going to be failing all that
though you're trying to provide the
service so one idea to see the scale is
a little bit about what Dilip talked
about so let me just sort of skip over
what he did and just give you an idea
these are the data centers that were
current about two or three years ago
Philippe mentioned that there were the
size of a football field they are each
one of them has floor space equivalent
to about 11 and a half football fields
it actually doesn't really matter
whether you're talking about us football
or the rest of the world they're roughly
the same size they're a little soccer
pitches are actually a little bit bigger
but it doesn't really matter for this
point the Chicago datacenter delete
mentioned is 17 science times the size
of a football field these are genuinely
huge buildings I mean if you've ever
walked into one of these things it's
walking out of computer science walking
into large scale industry I mean just
just different scale of things and it
really indicates the infrastructure and
a concrete embodiment of what you have
to do to sort of be able to handle the
demand that comes around the world on
the other hand if you look at the
programming that you need to do it's a
lot of the same problems that we've been
struggling with in computer science for
as long as I've been doing it and even
beyond that you know concurrency
parallelism message passing distribution
high availability performance
partitioning defect detection high-level
abstractions all these things are the
same challenges that we've dealt
with before and we don't necessarily
have good solutions for them but we're
going to have to go and back and revisit
them and a lot of the word i'm going to
talk about in the next few slides or why
these problems are still challenges for
us in this space and why we can't get
away from them and can't use the old
solutions so let me start with
concurrency um all you probably have
seen this but the web and the cloud
computing is inherently concurrent
basically the mode of communication for
most of it is messages messages arrive
asynchronously you need some sort of
internal concer currency to be able to
deal with messages to be able to do with
the fact the messages arrived out of
order that they arrive at unpredictable
times the other thing is that we share
resources in the cloud basically one
server is processing many many different
users requests at the same time and so
we have to be able to handle multiple
requests streams and so there's
concurrency involved in that this is
just a fact of life you have to write
software with the function from the
beginning it's not like writing desktop
software where you can pretty well hide
the concurrency on the other hand the
reason that all this stuff actually
works is that that most of this
concurrency is essentially independent
it's embarrassingly parallel we have a
lot of it which is great because we can
take advantage of sort of scale out
resources and it doesn't interact very
much so we don't actually have to do a
lot of synchronization and sharing on
the other hand we don't have a great
idea of how to deal with concurrent
programming the two ways that people
have proposed in the past or basically
threads or events so do you handle a
request by giving it a thread and
allowing it to block when it's waiting
for something to occur or do you write
event handlers to get fired when message
arrives and the next step of the
processing goes they're both perfectly
reasonable ways of handling concurrency
they've been used in different systems
to different degrees and sometimes
they're even intermixed together they
have their advantages and their
disadvantages but neither one has ever
been able to win the war over the other
one and so what we have is we have this
fracture where some people belong to
this camp some people belong to this
camp some languages go
here some languages come there and it
makes it very very hard for us to teach
people how to program this kind of
concurrency because there's not a single
model we can start with and it makes it
very hard and in some cases to share
code because it's very difficult to
translate between one model and the
other um there's also been a lot of
interest in higher level models state
machines which distract away from the
details or actors um there's very little
consensus about these models and whether
they're actually a good idea or not I
would argue that this is one of the sort
of real key areas for us to focus in on
because the lack of consensus in this
area makes research difficult because
part of the world is going in that
direction part of the world is going in
this direction and we've been going in
those two directions for 30 years
without any resolution makes it hard to
do development when some of the people
want to go this way and some want to go
that way reuse is obviously difficult as
well you know do I think that there's an
answer to this I'm not sure I think I'd
you know I used to believe in one side
or the other and I can tell you in my
career chosen both sides and changed my
mind but these days I'm actually much
more interested in the higher level
models and the reason for that is that I
look out and see the vast world of
programmers many of whom have no
experience in concurrency because they
grew up on simpler environments and I
say how do we move them into this world
where concurrency is inherent and I
think the answer is higher level models
and i'll talk about ours a little later
there's also parallelism in this world
basically as dilip indicated all the
machines that we use our parallel
machines you know this is the way the
world is going because we've run out of
the ability to increase the clock speed
so things are just becoming more
parallel and I think in the future
they're also going to become more
heterogeneous because if you really want
to use power efficiently you design
functional units that's do one task and
do it very well and in the data center
there's a lot of room for this kind of
optimization if we're really concerned
about efficiency and cost and power we
can do specialization on the computer
which means that the the the data center
is not going to be a collection of
uniform machines that are identical to
each other you know parallel
I don't need to sort of bring this up in
this audience it's a long-standing
challenge for the community we've been
at it for a long time without really
sort of coming to any kind of consensus
or resolution on it and you know my
proposal in the data center is basically
to get rid of one form of parallelism
which is the shared memory parallel ISM
and basically just say we have to do
message passing between machines so
let's do message passing on a machine as
well let's just basically simplify our
life get rid of one way of programming
parallel machines and concentrate on the
one that we actually have to have and
I'll explain how this actually works in
the model that I have a little bit later
message passing little to say there
except that there has been too little
language support for message passing in
the past message passing is typically a
library you load into a language that
has sort of bindings and it doesn't
actually work all that well because it's
asynchronous and synchronous language
and that's a difficult thing to do I
think that their languages where it has
been integrated which actually show the
way or allowing for instance integrates
messages with the pattern matching in
the language in a way that's very nice
and it makes it very easy to write the
message handling code by just pattern
matching on the contents of the message
in the singularity language sing sharp
we actually looked at putting contracts
on the messages so you could write the
protocol and we could statically analyze
your code to make sure you handle all
the cases that would arise in the
protocol and that found a lot of errors
in our code as well there are lots of
things that could be done I think this
is a great area for us to focus in on as
a community let me skip this to save
some time you know next real challenging
are in building this kind of software is
distributed systems everybody knows
we're building distributed systems it's
been a great research area for the
community they've come up with some very
very powerful techniques of rep for
replication consistency in court and
quorum consensus they're also not easy
techniques to sort of give to developers
who aren't first than they are so how do
we hide the complexity of these
techniques
make them into routine programming tools
it's a real challenge because you know
for instance this takes something as
simple as replication as soon as you
replicate your data and you know that's
what you do to avoid failure to get
better bandwidth out of a particular
part of your system once you replicate
it as long as it's changing you have
this problem of consistency you know
we're all used to a world in which you
read you write something and you read it
and you get back to value but suppose
you wrote something and then read it and
you didn't get back to value could you
live with that are there parts of your
application that you could live with it
are there other parts where you
absolutely can't live with that you know
most people don't think about things
that way yet you're going to have to in
a distributed world and another issue
obviously availability if you're
building a service that is used by a
large number of people you need to make
it available all the time in spite of
the fact that it's running on a failed
little platform the spite of the fact
that the networks that connect it to
users are failing as well it's a real
challenge because it requires
engineering to actually do this and it
requires a lot of operator discipline
that's why a lot of people I think are
going to end up depending upon services
like Azure because a lot of the
discipline of of actually keeping the
system running can be outsourced to a
organization like Microsoft or Amazon or
somebody that actually specializes in it
and that's difficult to do on the other
hand you know you actually have to build
the underlying software to tolerate
failure and that's something we don't
really know how to do all that well if
you look at failure handling in
programming languages it's a real source
of errors you know previous to this i
was looking at software defects in for a
long time at microsoft and we found a
lot of errors in the error handling code
and it's just natural it's the code that
gets written last it's the code that
doesn't get tested very thoroughly it's
the code that's very difficult to write
because the state of the world is very
confused when it's actually running but
if you're actually going to handle
errors and continue operating that's the
code that has to work how do we
incentivize people how do we give them
abstractions that allow them to write
reliable systems
in spite of the fact that pieces of the
system are failing how do we handle
errors in a way that's easy to
understand and and makes it possible to
do it in a successful way these are
programming questions performance you
know all of you sort of probably believe
performance is less of an issue it turns
out that when you move into this space
performance becomes a different issue
it's no longer so much the performance
of one core on a machine that matters to
you or the low level performance of the
central part of your algorithm things
that you've never thought about before
like the performance of the tcp/ip stack
start mattering a lot to you the fact
that there are packets colliding and
that they're colliding at the Machine
that's receiving them or they're
colliding on a single Ethernet segment
start to dominate the performance of
your system so you know how do we make
this either transparent to people so
that it doesn't occur or how do we make
it so that you can actually understand
what's going on in the many levels of
abstraction below your software that are
on the system you know because one of
the things that we're doing is making
the software stack unto you a lot more
complicated it's not only the operating
system and the network stack on the
machines that are running there but it's
also the entire operating system and
network stack running on all the
switches in the data center as well and
those are written by somebody else and
have very complicated behaviors as well
so how do we you know teach people to do
this how do we also teach people to
architect software that's going to scale
so you know you're fortunate enough to
start up a new service and it becomes
wildly popular and you go from zero to
four hundred million customers how do
you write a system that you don't have
to throw away and rewrite continuously
to keep up with the growth that's a
challenge you know this is scale out is
an easy thing to say it's a difficult
thing to achieve I talked about the rich
clients how do we partition the
application between the client and the
server how do we partition the
applications so that you can have
clients of widely different power or
computability or memory and
still use the same code across different
clients and and on the same on the
server side so that you don't have to
rewrite your code for every new client
that comes along right now there are two
fundamentally different applications and
they're basically just connected by a
sort of high-level protocol across the
wire an HTTP protocol typically is there
a better way of doing it so you don't
actually have to write these as separate
applications and deal with the divide
between them errors yeah they're going
to be lots of errors in the system
they're going to be a lot more
complicated errors because they're going
to occur not only on the machine you're
running on but on lots of other machines
many of which you may not even know
about in the data center how do you
reflect these errors back into the
programming model in a way in which
developers can actually understand them
so high level abstractions I think this
is another sort of key challenge for the
programming community all of you are
probably familiar with MapReduce which
is turned out to be a sort of wonderful
abstraction for talking about a
particular type of computation typically
a large-scale data processing problem it
works very well for that but there are a
lot of other things that go on in cloud
computing in particular in the
interactive applications that don't fit
into the MapReduce paradigm but is there
a similar high level paradigm that we
could use to describe this type of
interactive computation where people
could write small parts of it and the
runtime system could handle large
portions of it and relieve the
developers of the complexity I think
that's a central challenge in making
cloud computing successful ok so I'm a
programming languages guy so the answer
to all these things is clearly it's a
programming problem my advisor had this
had this slogan he basically said when
you're got a hammer everything looks
like a nail so I start with programming
languages and so everything looks like a
programming language problem to me the
system that we're building right now is
called Orleans basically it's a
framework that's built on top of dotnet
and its goal is to provide a simple
widely accessible programming
model and why the accessible means
accessible to the sort of the vast
majority of software developers we're
not aiming at sort of people who work
for facebook or twitter or Microsoft
we're aiming at sort of the large number
of people who want to build scalable web
services we're trying to encourage the
use of a software architecture that's
scalable and resilient in many ways what
we're trying to do is raise the level of
abstraction so those are you who are
familiar with windows know that there's
the CLR the whole net platform that sits
on top of Windows it gives you a higher
level programming model a much more safe
programming model safe programming
languages garbage collection vas
libraries of functionality to make it a
lot more efficient to write code so what
we're trying to do is we're trying to
provide the CLR or the dotnet platform
for cloud computing we're sitting on top
of asher instead of windows because as
you're is the operating system for the
data center and we're trying to give you
the higher level programming model the
model we started with is a fairly simple
model called actors many of you have
heard it it's been around for a long
time we call the actors greens which are
units of computation they basically
encapsulate some data and they have a
computation in it we can move the grains
around both within and between data
centers they were designed to be easily
migrated right from the beginning all
the issues about replication and
consistency and persistence of grains
are handled by the runtime system rather
than the user these are sort of
orthogonal concerns building blocks that
you use to build these systems not
things that you should have to implement
in your code another thing about the
grains is that they have a very simple
concurrency model each one of the grains
is single threaded it gets a high level
a top level request it processes it to
completion when it's sent the response
back it gets the next request we don't
try to have concurrency within the
grains so we don't have to worry about
locking of the data structures within
the grains if you want concurrency
basically for your
if you want to get through put in the
system you replicate the grains we have
different activations of the grain and
that's each of them is processing a
separate requests and so we get
concurrency that way but they're
isolated from each other so in many ways
they're like transactions in the sense
that you don't really care what else is
running at the same time in terms of
these grains obviously there's an issue
you have multiple activations of the
grains that are changing the shared
state we have to worry about making that
shared state consistent between the
activations and we do we have a simple
transaction like model that allows us to
ensure that the state remains in a the
state remains consistent even though
it's being modified by multiple grains
at one time we're developing one
programming model for both the client
and the server side of things and so the
idea is that you write your your code
using grains regardless of whether the
grains are going to run on the server or
the client and in fact we're we are
experimenting with dynamic binding so
that the the assignment of agreeing to
the client or the server side can be
done at runtime or we can actually
hopefully someday migrate them between
the client and the cert and the data
center or the data center and the client
so here's a picture basically you can
imagine you know your data center is
there running on Azure there's the
Orleans runtime and the blue things and
there are grains and within the to the
grains there are activations which are
the black instances of the grain they
communicate using messages and on the
clients over there they're similar or
liens runtime probably a little lighter
weight than what we would have on the
server and it also has the same
programming model and the communication
occurs between them and then on top of
that is the the application code or the
basically application code is built
using these grains and so this is a
fairly simple model hopefully you know
we can provide a lot of functionality in
the libraries that go along with Orleans
as well so that you don't have to write
nearly as much code and we've been
experimenting with building some fairly
large functionality lie
for instance for handling very large
distributed graphs which seemed to come
up very frequently for instance and
social networking to represent the
connections between the users you know
the architecture of the Orleans runtime
system is basically to take a lot of
functionality that we see people
implementing again and again across all
of the different cloud computing
applications and bring it into the
runtime so things like geo distribution
where you basically want to run your
computation on different data centers so
that you're tolerant to the failure of
the data center or you're located closer
to the user so you reduce the latency of
communication to the user performance
monitoring basically how do you know
what your system is doing well the only
way you're going to do it no what's
actually going on is to continually
monitor the performance that's a very
challenging task for a distributed
system because there are a lot of
separate pieces running and the volume
of data you collect is huge correctness
monitoring same thing basically there's
something which is called a gray failure
which is an interesting concept which
basically for one of these systems means
that part of your system has failed
you're not aware that it's failed but
it's affecting the behavior of the
performance of your system and you have
no idea how to fix it and this
apparently occurs fairly frequently in
this world is that literally failures
occur and nobody notices of them at
least nobody who's running the system
notices them i think the consumers of
the system typically see the side
effects of them data replication and
consistency i already sort of mentioned
the sort of key and central importance
of this in building reliable systems and
building high-performance systems if we
couldn't replicate computation and we
couldn't replicate data we couldn't
build this kind of system but once
you've replicated you have to worry
about consistency and we would like to
sort of raise that out of the level of
the code that it developer has to write
and make that something that system
provides as a service adaptive control
can we actually build control systems
that can watch the behavior of your
system
and adapt to it can we grab more
machines for now sir as the load goes up
can we release them back to as er as the
load goes down can we handle failure by
invoking recovery routines that's
adaptive control debugging a huge
problem and then a lot more prosaic
issues things like deployment how do you
deploy what is an application how do you
deploy it across a large number of
machines in the data center what happens
when a new user comes on board how do
you configure a system how do you change
the configuration how do you do
maintenance on a system have you ever
thought about how do you upgrade a
service that's running 7 by 24 on a data
center do you do it one machine at a
time do you do it one big chunk you sort
of what happens if you get halfway
through and you realize there's a bug in
the upgrade can you roll it back these
are very very challenging engineering
problems so the type of thing that
really needs to be solved well and
solved once so that people can build on
top of it instead of pushing the
responsibility to every developer so
another view of it is let me just sort
of skip that so I think this one is
actually probably a better picture of
what's what we're trying to provide so
the idea with these grains which are the
ovals here are that we're going to
provide a number of different services
to them things like replication so you
can have multiple instances of grain
migration persistence will be able to
store them in stable storage and then
also my mobility will be able to move
the grains to either do load balancing
within the data center or move them on
to the client device or off the client
device for various reasons you can
imagine starting a computation on your
cell phone and then you know the data is
not locally being more efficient to move
it to where the data is you know Jim
Gray's paradigm move the computation not
the data or you realize there's not
enough battery power on your cell phone
to complete the computation you move it
into the data center to finish it and
then bring back the results lots of
different scenarios are enabled by my
mobility big deal in this is really
separation of concerns is can we
separate the abstractions the ideas that
you need
build this type of application from the
code that the user rights if we can then
there's a hope that we can actually
bring in a large number of programmers
teach them about these abstractions when
they're ready to be used without having
to feed them through a distributed
system course and teach them how to
write all of these abstractions as part
of their code themselves another big
issue we've been struggling with is how
do you compose grains so you know I
build a service that's based on grains
you build a service that's based on
grains how do we put them together in a
way in which preserves the desirable
properties of both of them you know do
we just wire them together by exchanging
messages is that done externally with
some sort of manifest stores are done by
just like tcp/ip where you connect to a
particular port on a service the
lifecycle are for anybody who's actually
gone and built the service and actually
run it this is the biggest challenge you
know it's easy enough to do the code
development but to keep the service up
and running and maintain it is a huge
engineering challenge and a continuous
engineering challenge and something that
really needs to be shifted on to the
platform rather than the individual
applications another interesting area
which i think is an open area is cloud
tools so the tools we have for debugging
and finding errors in systems do not
scale to anything near what we have how
do you do bugs 10,000 machines in the
data center that are running say a
million separate tasks all of which are
independent only some small fraction of
which are failing at any one time how do
you even identify where the failures
occur how do you identify performance
bottlenecks in a system of the size how
do you find them how do you monitor to
them so that you can see hardware
failure or attacks on your system there
are very very few tools that are
addressing scale at this issue and by
tools I mean either things that come out
of the research community or things that
are sitting in commercial operating
systems like what Microsoft or our
competitors has they just don't exist
yet
skip a few of these so in conclusion
basically I'm taking the term cloud
computing and tried to raise it to a
higher level than what most people use
it most people think of it as a fairly
prosaic think the platform is a service
that Amazon provides or the services
that Microsoft provides basically the
sort of low-level infrastructure that
allows you to get started I actually see
cloud computing is a much more
interesting thing this combination of
vast computing and data resources that
are available across the networks and a
profusion of very interesting clients
that are coming up that are connected
together this is a platform this is a
new platform this is one that opens up
lots of great challenges there are a lot
of things we can do with the this
platform one of my fondest hopes is that
we can actually correct some of the
mistakes we made the last time around
when we built all the software that we
use day to day whether it's on pcs or
Macs or everything else there are a lot
of bad choices we made back in an error
of much more limited resources that were
impossible to fix my hope is that this
time around we can actually sort of
learn from our mistakes and build a
platform that's much easier for people
to use a much more resilient and
tolerant of people's mistakes and
failings and make it so that computing
is much more natural for the rest of the
world that doesn't have a computer
science degree I say this is a great
area it's a huge challenge for the
programming languages the compilers the
distributed systems the operating
systems you name a computer architecture
the entire computer science research
community really should be getting
around this and seeing this as a source
of new problems new challenges new
things that you can actually address
using a lot of the same techniques that
you've seen before but a lot of new
contexts and a lot of different issues
of scale and reliability and continuous
operation so I think I have a few
minutes left for questions
yeah well the cloud computers you're
talking about are about a 30th the size
of say blue waters are there lessons we
can learn from HP see that would apply
to clouds that's a that's a very good
question I don't know enough about the
sort of detailed lessons of what the HPC
community learned from running on that
scale of system to to exactly draw
analogs I would assume that some of the
challenges they faced are the same
challenges I know some of the solutions
they did like checkpointing don't really
have an obvious analog in this world you
know on the other hand I think in many
ways the challenges are different in
this space they're easier because you
have a huge amount of embarrassing
parallelism but it's essentially
independent parallelism you know while
on a machine like blue waters most of
them processors are dedicated to running
one particular computation that's very
much tightly connected and I think one
of the advantages we have is that you
can fail on one little computation and
continue running the rest of the system
and still get useful results out of it
so I think it's an interesting direction
to look at and probably a lot of
engineering that was done on the actual
hardware that would be relevant to pull
into the data center space as well yeah
I think though there's a lot of
interesting issues because trying to
keep 300,000 machines running is next to
impossible so they will be running with
a large number of machines that failed
and have problems so there's a lot of
commonality between in the data center
space that's just taken as an assumption
that a given as you heard from the
earlier talks is that you know you just
start from the assumption that some part
of what you're going to want to do is
either not available or fails while
you're actually trying to use it and
those try to work forward from
yeah yeah the flip side so much
impossible to back up 300,000 machines
yes thank you for the great talk about
the challenges we're within the cloud
computing in fact you have laid out a
very good news of their or the
challenges that we have from distribute
computing and high-performance computing
and maybe some of them could be
addressed within the cloud platform I
have a question regarding how do you as
a platform designer developer on
provider point of view how do you define
the responsibility of the users the
programmer and the pro platform
providers who's going to take care of
which part the reason I'm trying to ask
is for example if I'm a user and cloud
is supposed to be pay-as-you-go and I
have a little scientific problem I want
to put on the cloud but I don't know how
much computing convene I need I don't
want to explode my wallet yeah yeah
those those issues of you know around
the business model the pricing model and
so forth are you know I think in flux
right now I mean we've started with
fairly simple models basically a certain
number of cents per CPU hour and we
basically put all of the burden onto the
user to figure out how much they're
going to need and probably given some
tools to limit it but in the future I
think that we're going to move too much
more sophisticated pricing models
because that model doesn't give us as
the cloud provider any indication of how
important your computation is to you and
how much are really willing to pay to
get enough resources to finish it which
means that we can't really use our data
center as efficiently as we want to you
know we would like to know which jobs
are really important that we actually
have to dedicate resources and which
ones we could do best effort in which
ones we should just run in the
background as just sort of noise
computations to soak up cycles and so I
think that the world is going to move in
the direction of much more interesting
contracts between the various levels we
there you know some of the contracts are
going to be monetary some of them are
going to be things like service level
agreements where we specify a desired
level of performance as well we just
have time for one more so to me you have
a very exciting a vision of what cloud
computing of the future can be I'm
reminded of what's happened with the
global telephone network and the
internet and there's a notion of
universal bearer service that has
allowed these things to both grow and
expand and there's also the importance
of agreed-upon protocols the
International Telecommunications Union
publishes protocols that every telephone
company in the world has to conform to
the IETF has its sets of protocols can
you see a parallel for having uniform
protocols so that people can
interoperate with their services in this
kind of view of the cloud yeah I think
actually now there are some de facto
styles of protocols I wouldn't call them
protocols because I don't think they're
formally specified so things like the
soap protocols which allowed you to do
remote procedure call between different
systems and then things like the rest
interfaces that people build which allow
you to at least talk at a certain level
to a system regardless of what hardware
software platform it's running on you
know the higher level protocols which
actually start involving the semantics
of the application are obviously a lot
more challenging but essential to
building interoperability you know I
hope that we get enough experience that
we can actually start talking about that
and start you know assembling higher
level building blocks to build our
software you know if you can basically
sort of take a large unit of
functionality like you know here is a
billing service so that you know
building my application I don't have to
worry about billing just like I don't
have to worry about authentication if I
run using Microsoft's passport you know
those are the components that actually
could allow people to build new
ideas very much more efficiently than
they can now because building something
like a billing service is a huge amount
of work and it's the kind of thing that
people do over and over again and you
know that that's the level of interface
that I think we should be working
towards in the future I don't think Jim
once more thank you what now our next
speaker is jimmy lin he's an associate
professor from the I school at the
University of Maryland he's done a lot
of great work with on the application
side and looking at MapReduce
computations now he is up against avatar
at four o'clock and so we want to dr.
say anymore let him get started you took
away my opening line so I i I'm the one
that's standing view between you guys
and avatar so I don't think this is
going to be quite as interesting so I'll
try to keep on time the second thing I
realize is that the order of the talks
was actually flipped should have
actually been flipped around I should
have come up here and told you what
we're doing now and then Jim can offer
his vision of the future but oh we have
to oh I didn't realize yes yeah I can
start from here also ok ok so i renamed
the ton of my talks slightly embracing
the data de luge data-intensive
computing for the masses ok so a little
bit of background i come from a text
processing background I work on natural
language processing information
retrieval so I'm going to be approaching
cloud computing more from the
applications in so the starting point of
the talk is that is quite
uncontroversial statement at this point
is we live in a world of large data and
to stay relevant we got to embrace it so
in my own area of text processing over
the last couple decades we've seen the
emergence and dominance of empirical
data driven techniques and so if we
don't keep up with the tide we get
reviews back on our papers that say oh
this is an uninteresting result on a toy
conclusion toys uninteresting result on
a toy data set reject or the other
alternatives we spent way too long
waiting for experiments to complete so
neither are good good alternatives in
the area of the Natural Sciences we've
talked about
quite a bit at this at this faculty
summit the emergence of the fourth
paradigm data-intensive e-science and
i'm happy that makes me happy because
they're difficult computer science
problems there and that's job security
right so what I'll be doing in my talk
is presenting two case studies of how we
practically scale up to large datasets
I'm going to present a case study from
my own area of expertise and natural
language processing and unsettle machine
translation and I'm going to talk a
little bit about some work I've been
doing with colleagues in in bio mattox
about a DNA sequence alignment okay so
let's start with a basic question how
much data is it is it really out there
and so this is a slide I actually have
to update quite frequently I just
updated a few months ago Facebook came
out with this statistic that they're
storing thirty six petabytes of user
data probably most of it not useful and
it's growing about 80 to 90 degree bites
a day CERN's LHC the Large Hadron
Collider last time I they turned it on
they had what Mike physicist colleagues
called a higher energy event which is a
euphemism for an explosion I've heard
that's been fixed now so any day now the
the spigot will be turning on and we'll
be getting 15 petabytes a year the
Astronomy community with the LSST which
is going to come online in 2015 isn't
very far behind they're estimating six
to 10 petabytes year and so whenever I
talk is slide I have to bring up a
picture of this guy anybody recognize
who this is this is billy g right so it
wasn't that long ago when you said you
know 640k ought to be enough for
everybody and I can imagine somebody
standing in the same place of maybe a
decade or two from now saying wow back
then two terabytes 22 petabytes that's
it ok all right so what do we do with
all that data so for those of you in the
audience that are pearl hackers this is
basically what we do when in doubt
instead of trying to be smart we simply
throw more data at it ok so I'll give
you a couple results that are sort of
that sort of highlight what I'm talking
about so this was a for work actually
done at microsoft research about 10
years ago this is a very simple
supervised mission learning task on the
x-axis here we
have the amount of training data this
was i believe grammar correction but the
task really is is not relevant on the y
axis we have simple accuracy in
reporting the performance of different
machine learning algorithms so the
important thing to take away is that
well it really doesn't matter what
algorithm you're working as long as you
give it more data when the performance
uniformly increases and second the the
the performance basically converges and
so the controversial statement at that
time was that well we should just all
quit our jobs and go out and gather more
data right so fast forward recently more
recently there's a the similar results
by published by google in 2007 with
large-scale language models for machine
translation they basically have the same
experimental setup they have language
models trained on increasing order
magnitude of data and they have some
figure of merit and in this case
measuring machine translation accuracy
holding everything else constant the
more data you throw at it performance
increases and so there's this joke I'd
like to say in that in the text
processing community there's basically
only one graph it looks like this so we
draw the graph first and we just fill in
the scales later right yes yes you can
sort of squint and say yeah the the
slope is decreasing a little bit but it
still has remained true as far as we
observe the more data you throw at it
the better the better your algorithms
get right so the focus of what I've been
really thinking about the last few years
is well how do we get here if we're not
Google right and so cloud computing is
of course the answer and and so what is
the path to data nirvana and I think
this is sort of my take on it so with
the advent of cheap commodity clusters
in utility computing you know the
previous talks you've heard about in
this session combined with simple and
distributed programming models you you
get data intensive computing for the
masses okay now you might be a little a
little bit skeptical at this point I
mean haven't you heard this story before
this is simply the you know parallel
processing parallel parallelism is a way
of the future story that's been told for
the last couple of / last couple decades
right so why is this different well and
so let me try to explain why so parallel
computing is hard and that's the only
way we can scale up to large data sets
right these are just some of the things
that we teach our students fundamental
issues architectural issues different
programming models common problems
different programming constructs etc but
when it when the rubber meets the road
the reality is that the programmers
shoulders all the burden of managing
concurrency in traditional programming
paradigms and I'm not happy with that I
don't like that from an applications
point of view because I want my students
did we be developing machine learning
algorithms not debugging race conditions
right so this is and so if they're not
careful they get into jams like this
that then I have to come and fix or help
them fix right so where is the what's
the problem where where do I place the
blame I sort of say this tongue-in-cheek
but this is where I put the blame in so
this is a standard von Neumann
architecture and the problem is is this
is what's been guiding us over the last
half a century and as we move into data
centers as we move into the multi cool
world well we'll have what have we done
well we simply taken this and cloned it
and times and then entire data center
and so we're still managing all the
details at the level we shouldn't be yet
and so I this is the wrong approach and
this isn't actually a new message right
this is the same that you've heard
reinforced several times throughout the
day we should be thinking about
abstractions at the level and an entire
data centers right so Lewis barossa was
uh was a person who said at the data
center is the computer and we should be
thinking of us as such right okay so
this is um this is where MapReduce comes
in so I realized over the layout course
of the last couple days that not all the
invitees the summit are from our
computer scientist so so for the benefit
of those that are non computer
scientists let me just spend a couple to
flies talking about MapReduce in what
what I think is important about it okay
so MapReduce in a couple slaw and a
couple words is functional programming
meets distributed processing it's sort
of a generic recipe of that has two
steps so there's one parallelism step in
which there
per record per record operations you do
in parallel and then there's a reduced
step where you aggregate summit results
to generate final output so in a
MapReduce programming style the
programmer specifies two functions a map
and reduce they operate on key value
pairs so a map takes an input key value
pair and generates any arbitrary number
of intermediate key value pairs the
reduce on the other hand you can imagine
as a big group by operation all the key
value pairs with the same key get
grouped together and then a reduced
computation happens and the nice thing
about it is that basically from a
developer point of view you specify the
map and the reviews and that's it well
not quite accurate there's some of the
things you have to specify but that's
about it and the execution framework
handles everything else right handles
scheduling it handles data management
the transport and handles
synchronization and handles faults and
errors and all those all those complex
things in a that I put on a few slides
back right so here's a here's a picture
of how MapReduce works in in a in
animation so you have input key value
pairs you run them through a mapper you
get some intermediate key value pairs
there's this big sword and shuffle dance
in which all the values are aggregated
by key and the reduce and the reduced
computation happens to get you some
final output okay now why is this good
for our from my point of view well it's
good from my point of view because from
the developer perspective the the data
center becomes a black box literally all
I have to give my students is they
access to where the master cement node
is and that's all it is where the right
there programs they submit their jobs on
the cluster and things magically happen
it's a black box to them never mind that
behind the scenes the framework the
execution framework is managing a whole
bunch of complex operations scheduling
the individual workers moving the data
around and all those issues I talked
about before and this makes me very
happy because well I said earlier I want
my students developing new machine
learning algorithms not debugging race
conditions check right okay so a little
bit more about MapReduce so Google has a
proprietary implementation in c plus
plus plus bindings
in Java and Python and a couple others
Hadoop which was is this guy this yellow
elephant is an open-source
implementation in Java of the
programming model was development was
led by yahoo and is actually used in
production by yahoo it's now an Apache
project and the what excites me is
there's a rapidly growing software
ecosystem around it and beyond beyond
you know Google's implementation and the
open-source Hadoop implementations there
are lots of custom research
implementation so there's MapReduce for
GPUs there's MapReduce for cell
processors and any type of even for fpga
so any type of hardware you can think of
okay so let me talk about a little bit
my first case study in statistical
machine translation okay so let me give
you a run-through how machine how modern
statistical machine translation works so
it's all data driven and in its
dependent on two types of two types of
corpora so you want to get your hands on
a lot of what we call parallel sentences
which are translations of sentence in
one language another where do you get
them you get them from places like the
United Nations in which documents are
disseminated in multiple languages you
get them in for example the Canadian
Parliament where everything is in
English and French so that's one source
of data and the other sorts of data is
target language text for most of these
applications are translating into
English and so the target language text
is just um you can just crawl the web
basically okay so you take the parallel
sense you run them through a lineman
process using an
expectation-maximization algorithm and
what that basically does is a billing
correspondences the best if its
knowledge between words and foreign
language and words in words in the
language are trying to trying to
translate into which is English in most
cases and from that you extract these
phrases the phrases having absolutely no
linguistic meaning in this phrase is
just indicating consecutive sequence of
tokens so you learn these patterns that
you know this this this this consecutive
sequence of tokens and this language
tends to map it in in that language from
the ward alignment process that goes
into what's called the translation model
on the other hand you you take the
target language text
build a language model from it so you
pry a cider a probability distribution
over over text in your in your language
okay and that goes all into the decoder
and from there you basically have your
machine translation system in comes a
foreign unseen input sentence and output
comes out comes the translation okay so
how does this work well translation you
can think of it sort of as a tiling
problem right so you start off with your
foreign language sentence you go up in
your phrase table that's up in the
right-hand corner there and you sort of
look at all the possible translations
that the phrase can can match and what
you're trying to do is you're trying to
find a you're treating it as a tiling
problem you're trying to find a covering
of the foreign language sentence that
maximizes the probability of being a
good sense in the target language as as
determined by the target language model
right so in this case it might be
something like a path through this and
you accomplish this through something
like beam search for example and this
would be a good translation okay so you
throw data at the problem what are the
effects so here on the on this graph
here i have a corpus sighs this is
training data size in terms of number of
parallel sense and on the y-axis here we
have just a figure of merit of how good
the translation is so you see in the in
the in the squares on the left through
here you have the the amount of time it
takes to train up the model so in the
solid squares you see of course as
amount of data increases the training
time goes up and and of course as you
gave it more data the translation
quality improves also holding everything
else constant and so this is a great
time to bring this quote a quite famous
quote from colleague a ba in the field
Fred jellinek every chi says famously
said every time I fire linguist the poor
performance of our system goes up and
this is that this requires absolutely no
knowledge about the about language all
right so what we've done what we've done
what well the students have been working
with have done is build MapReduce
implementations of these two components
so let me give you some of the valuation
figures to
to give you some to give you a sense of
what's going on so we focus in
particular on the word alignment problem
and so there is an existing open source
tool kit that you can go out and
download right now it's called Giza and
here's here is its performance profile
so here on the x axis we have size of
the collection on y-axis we have
training time this is an iterative
algorithm so typically you run maybe
half a dozen iterations so the training
time on a single core commodity to
server is on the order of an entire day
so we built a MapReduce implementation a
bit and got essentially a performance
profile something that looks like this
on a 38 processor 38 core cluster so
innovation goes from about three hours
to about three minutes now of course
this is an app this is not fair right
because you're comparing a single core
against a 38 core processor and so what
I've shown in this graph is taken simply
the top line and / 38 to demonstrate
what the ideal skilling characteristics
would be so the thing that you notice is
well with a MapReduce implementation
we're not that far off from ideal
paralyzation no difference between three
minutes and maybe two minutes some two
minutes and change and you really only
care about large data because that's the
condition we want we want to throw all
the data we have at it right so so
what's the point well the point is that
this mythical optimally paralyzed
version doesn't exist right whereas on
the other hand I think the argument we
make is that MapReduce occupies a sweet
spot in the design space for large class
of problems as this the has is three
nice properties it's fast in terms of
running time and it's the scaling
characteristics pretty close to optimal
it's easy in terms of programming effort
this this whole reimplement ation was
done on the order of months and it's to
achieve in terms of hardware costs and
being able to utilize commodity clusters
and so this is work well we we published
a couple years ago so this is pretty old
news by now okay the second case study I
want to talk about
is is a more recent work by Michael
Schatz who just this defended defended
the dissertation on this a few months
ago and just graduated about DNA
sequence alignment okay so to explain
the problem let me start with an analogy
okay so that's a Dickens in writing
until two cities had wrote it in a very
weird way he wrote it on a long spool
it's a long single spool very very long
so it was the best of times the worse of
course of time you of course realized
that this analogy is somewhat
tongue-in-cheek because it breaks down
very quickly right so that's also
assumed that Dickens happens to have
backup on for more coffees and so you
have all these spools and as he's going
to the publisher to get the spools
printed he trips and oops he
accidentally shreds the manuscript okay
now he's got a problem right so the
problem is can he reconstruct the text
all right so you have these little
little tiny fragments and copies from
each a fragments from each the copies or
mixed together some fragments identical
like be so can you put the manuscript
back together well you can think of
maybe something like a greedy approach
to putting the manuscript back together
you start with all the you start with
all the little little slices and you say
okay let's line them up that's take one
of them and you know that the the
writing has to be from contiguous spans
you say okay that's fine one that sort
of overlaps with it and then another one
that overlaps with that and then another
one that overlaps with that and so on
and so forth of course then you run into
this problem of well what if you get to
this right so in Dickens the the text
goes it was the best of times it was the
worst of times it was the age of wisdom
it was age of foolishness so we have
this repeat and so right here you have a
point of a branching where it's
unambiguous what the next next part
should be so the repeated sequence makes
the correct reconstruction ambiguous so
the approach that bioinformatics people
have developed is to treat this problem
and view it as a modeling sequence
construction as a graph as a graph
problem okay so let me explain how that
works
so what you're going to do is you're
going to this is called the de Bruyne
graph construction approach what you're
going to do is you're going to take
every original fragment and you're going
to create two vertices and an edge out
of it based on the overlap ok and so
what you do here is your you your you're
creating local graph structure and
implicitly you're revealing the global
graph structure and you can I can show
that very clearly in this animation here
right so once you do that to all the
segments you get something that looks
like this right so then you can clearly
see that an orlon tour of the graph
reconstructs the original text however
you still have the problem that there
may be multiple tours and so that's
that's the issue there and so feeling a
feeling having a unique oil erient or
what you want to do is simplify the
graph as much as possible ok so I
basically given you giving you an
overview of modern DNA sequence
alignment all you have to do now is take
a text construction and turn it over
into DNA sequences ok so this is a real
problem this is what happens so you
start with a subject kingdom of a
somebody that you want to a sequence
this may be from a blood sample from a
cheek swab something along those lines
run it through sequencers here are some
examples of what sequencers look like
and you get a whole bunch of these
snippets right in an 80 and C and G the
amino acids that make up DNA right so
the joke I like to make is well that's
kind of like text processing too right
they just have a smaller alphabet ok so
what you get out of it is a unique human
genome is about three Giga base pairs
and out of these out of the sequencers
you get about a few billion short reads
because their overlaps and there's
through plication and so all in all it's
about 100 gigabytes of compressed data
ok so what's the present solution of
stitching all of these back together per
the previous / the previous slide I
talked about well the present solution
involved large shared memory machines or
clusters with
high speed interconnects InfiniBand etc
right so their papers talking about
bringing clusters with a few tera bytes
of RAM or half a terabyte of RAM to bear
on the problem and and Mike's a
dissertation focus on this this
alternative can we get by with MapReduce
on cheap commodity clusters and the
answer is yes so I'll show you I'll show
you a small part of it okay so as it
turns out the largest the most important
problem from a computer science point of
view is this graph compression problem
you want to take this really large graph
that has a lot of sequence a lot of
small intimate individual sequences and
compress it down to something that looks
like this as it turns out without
knowledge from biology and the
biologists getting involved this is
pretty much the best that you can do
because in a human genome there are lots
of repeated region so for example you
can go into this loop and go around
hundreds of times sometime so you need
to get the biologists involved so the
challenge is working on MapReduce
framework is that the nodes are
partitioned and stored on separate
machines and the fact that notes only
have access to their direct successors
right so you only have the adjacency
list because there is no such thing as
global shared memory okay so how do we
solve this problem i'll give you a
sketch of the algorithm to just get a
flavor of hope we've been able to do it
so Mike came up with a randomized
solution so what you do first is you
assign a random and heads and tails to
each of the nodes that you think are
compressible and then you simply have
the head nodes seek out the tail nodes
there and have the tail notes past the
adjacency lists back to the head nodes
and there by compressing the graph and
so looks something like this so you do a
randomization you do one round of
compression you get down to something
like this and mutate the graph structure
of the process you do another
randomization and another another round
of compression you get to something like
this and then like this by this time you
can fit it a memory and then you put it
compressed at the rest of the way okay
so so that's just a sort of a flavor of
the types of things that he he's
implemented in MapReduce so here's some
results so he's built a system called
contrail a de novo assembly of a human
genome in this case it was a african
male input about 3.5 billion us
25 billion rupiah short little reads and
so here are some initial results
starting from initial graph about 7
billion knows once he applies the graph
compression he gets it down to about a
billion knows he has a other couple
tricks so for example there's a lot of
spurious tips he calls them based on
sequencing errors you can clip that
fairly easily based on sequencing errors
he also has what he calls bubbles and he
can pop the bubbles and you can do quite
well in grass simplification okay so
here's another case study of MapReduce
being applied to quite a different
problem domain okay so am and there's a
there's a manuscript currently under
preparation and so you'll read about it
soon okay so let me start wrapping up
here and sort of talk about where I see
where I see the future and where is this
all going so MapReduce it's the best
thing since sliced bread right no I
actually don't believe so right so it's
all about different distributed
programming models as many of the
speakers before we have talked about
MapReduce is probably the first
successful one at scale it's definitely
not the only and it's probably not even
the best and there are lots of
alternatives out there so for example
many in the open source community have
talked about well MapReduce is actually
too low level we should be programming
in something that's higher level so pig
is something that tries to foil to
fulfill that need so you can think of
pig as as perl scripting for for peta
scale peta size scale data sets of
course you've heard also about dry and
dry out link from microsoft the directed
acyclic graph model of computation
google recently talked about something
called prego which is their framework
for large-scale graph processing and so
III think the key here is it's right
it's all about finding the right level
of abstraction I mean what clearly
hasn't worked what this is I've argued
is that the von Neumann architecture
just is not cutting it anymore in this
multi core data center a cluster
computing world and so that's why I
think I think one important
in the second point is this is
separating the the how the what from the
how and I think that's a very important
insight and then this goes back to the
comment I made earlier about I might I
want my students developing machine
learning algorithms not debugging race
conditions right so I think this is
really the key we want a a developer to
be able to sort of specify the
computation that needs to be performed
and then have a free execution framework
just go and do the execution in the
cloud for us and having the framework
high system level details from the
developer is going to make applications
developer far more far more productive
and so if you think of if you really
believe that the data center is the is
the computer the collective question
that will be trying to answer in the
next few years as well what are the
appropriate abstractions for the for the
data set under computer okay something
I've been touched on which i think is
also important is the educational aspect
and so how do we teach our students to
be able to think add a petabyte scale
that's an important question that's
something I've devoted some effort to so
that's something I've actually had some
successes in so i've had i've been
running a series of MapReduce courses
target it at intro masters level
advanced undergrad level so and in fact
the first case study that you heard
about the the one in statistical machine
translation was actually a course
project between brats collaborating
between grad students and and undergrads
that was done in a course of a couple
months Michael Schatz also was one of
the early early takers of my MapReduce
programming course and I think it's fair
to say that the work that I presented
sort of was a little was inspired by
some of the stuff he he found out in my
class so uh that's that's about it I
wouldn't leave everybody with this final
thought so if if data is the rising tide
that lifts all boats than this
commoditization of large-scale
processing capabilities allow us to rise
up with a tide
and if we can why wouldn't we right so
I'll be happy to take any questions and
welcome your feedback we have time for a
few questions before we all move across
the hall yeah don't ask questions let's
go i'll see go go see avatar so one
thing that always is a big rub in these
kinds of systems when you talk about
large data is that large data isn't
isn't at all portable so if it's
generated in california and you have
several petabytes and you wanted you to
the compute computation somewhere else
you need to take the hard drives and
send them to that somewhere else so do
you have further thoughts about that as
the as a data grows and our bandwidth on
that data it travels away from the
computation exponentially we need other
ways of moving data around you want the
tongue-in-cheek answer or or or they
what the serious answer the
tongue-in-cheek answer is well a couple
sessions back you heard about data
centers and containers right so why
couldn't you if you want to move a
couple petabytes across country park a
container next to the thing you want to
transfer transfer it over put on a
flatbed driving across the country and
reverse the process so that's sort of
the tongue-in-cheek answer yes I think
that's a serious problem and I think a
lot of it at least for the stuff that
I'm interested is remedy by the fact
that I can do the computation where the
data is gathered right so I work with
web data well bits being crawled
somewhere and so might as well do the
computation on the cluster in which the
crawls being generated from same thing
with log analysis of the access to log
data so it's certainly not the general
case but I mean back to my tongue and
cheek answer I wouldn't underestimate
the the bandwidth of sneakernet of
shipping hard drives and from from what
I've heard you know Amazon you can ship
them hard drives and they will you know
handle it just like like any other
package that they handle and you know
load it onto their service for you for
example
olympic compute the ratio to compute to
the data makes sense for you so if it
costs you more time to send it you might
as well run it yes yes sending it there
yes yeah but for large data stuff I
think that is always going to be that
ratio always works out in your favor
that you want to you want to ship the
data another actually pointed on this is
that I think a large collection of large
data will be built by accumulation in
two data centers and if it trickles in
it builds up quite rapidly in some cases
and you have it right there web crawling
is a good example of that so the type of
data that Jimmy looks at text data stuff
that's been harvested really on the
other joke i like to make us i have made
the suggestion that for these people
that work on bioinformatics is that they
should just move their sequencers to
where the data centers are right and sin
send the send the samples over to the
data centers and so that you have a
direct pipe from the sequencing machine
into the data center yep okay oh we do
have one more one more question so my
question is around the bioinformatics
part how real is you're actually
assembler so it means do you take into
account continuous quality data do you
think about having longer reads like 200
base pairs or do you think about
estimating repetitive regions because I
mean this is very nice example but in
the real world it's actually a little
bit more complicated yeah so the reads
are getting longer but i don't think the
total amount i don't think the problem
is easier you're sort of i mean kiki
here its quality data because it's not
it's not 01 it's actually the beginning
of the sequence it's better quality
dentist was that you usually combined
between something good and something so
not good or something in video i think
you're exhausted mine for a my knowledge
about bioinformatics so i could
certainly put you in touch with my
colleagues a her but but i don't know
about Amy my question is did was it
actually designed as an experiment to
show to prove the concept was designed
as a real real life application a little
bit of both and I I don't I I'm actually
I actually don't know the answer to your
question on what not quality data was
taken into account
and one comment about the sequences
actually the sequencer data is not that
because it looks like because what we
actually deal is actually string of
ASCII characters that is for DNA a huge
data that sequence that everybody talks
about sequencing is actually pictures
images current out of the sequence and
which never go far from the sequences
because you cannot do anything with them
yeah all right I think at this point we
got 10 minute break before the show
starts in the next room thank you all
very much for coming to these sessions
thanks Jenny